c'est parti sacha elbaz qui doit être
encore en train de revenir d'une bar
mitzvah celle basile et là c'est parti
d'un dyke de l'ariège
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais je remonte en coulisses et
j'entends dans les couloirs on va
cueillir tout de suite l'indiquent
dallara l'axé c'est peut-être pas le bon
moment je suis à [ __ ] en coulisses
j'allais boire un peu un peu avant de
cette loi des volcans oui plus tard pas
grave vous savez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis président de merde là tu peux la
garder la non vous savez je suis à la
rédaction je suis professionnel
oui mais quand même qui va se réveiller
dans ton slip pas mal allez on sache où
on a quoi au bébé alors en un premier
magnéto sur vous cyril non et oui
pourquoi le problème en est ce que tu
fais quoi parce que toi lui dit c'est
que toutes les images wii d'indicés
coeur c'est tout je vois tout je suis
l'indiquent de la rédac
d'après lui c'est tout je vois tout est
le 1er mai et au cyril je résumerais
avec les 3e
c'est à dire est que la wii épiderme
ouais exfoliant quoi encore et oui je
parle de votre pôle cyril encore célèbre
lisez chaque jour mais votre peau ça a
l'air d'être le sujet qui vous préoccupe
le plus alors c'est avec guillaume
genton on a mis la rédaction qui est
vraiment un pote qu'est ce que ces cours
vous avez encore des indignés par
indiscrétion normalement le matin vous
êtes sensé bosser les sujets le
conducteur et ses bas non vous vous
préférez inculquer vos conseils beauté à
d'autres c'était pas le ciridd
l'animateur le ciri le producteur que
j'ai à côté de moi c'est le cirill
coiffeur visagiste eu plus les pages je
sais tout je suis même en réunion
[Musique]
je fais tu parles sur sa à trois fois
par jour et tu mets un les régimes
d'argent pour être toujours en
mouvements circulaires dans ce sens
inverse des aiguilles d'une montre comme
ceci oui culture manga petits jours
sinon ton visage travers le voir j'ai
toujours fait c'est quoi ta mort ni aux
dinos l'eau moi si je suis capable de
nos jours mais c'est ce truc accuse
camille le booste le bout ça c'est le
matin et comme pas du tout cette soirée
c'est toujours que c'est le soir il faut
apaiser évidemment je te dis c'est une
c'est une dermatologue qui m'a dit 'ça
contraire je mets ça pour booster vos de
pizzas et le matin j'ai une peau
resplendissante
il y a tout plein de trucs où je suis
vraiment pas du tout je regarde là en
dessous des yeux
il faut que tu faut que tu fasses un
toit était bien je sais que sa prime de
poche tu as un problème de poche
ces temps voulu te dirais même à faire
quelques séances d'uv moi j'ai un
nouveau truc c'est à nous à la tour 11
ans que tu l'as fait de même comme ça
mais comme ça c'est exceptionnel
mais non il ya un autre truc qui
fonctionnait en s'occupant des sources
ils étaient 6 août on regarde pas
beaucoup plus ressentir je sais pas où
tu vas capillairement et le cheveu est
comme ça il est de mèche avec la peau et
de laitages j'ai également un masque
bleu qui permet d'entretenir le buzz et
masque bleu ciel pour les colorations
écoute pour la coloration ne me prends
pas mon métier je suis leur jeu alors
j'ai dit ah c'est récent il ya pas 36
solutions de log et l'huile de ricin
pour de l'huile que d'afrique comme ça
sur le jaune et tu fé péi obtenir et
dans le cuir chevelu comme ceci tu vois
quand même guillaume est ce que je peux
demander un service
je voudrais que tu t'abandonnes amour
est-ce que tu acceptes là si je veux
travailler sur toi on ne touche plus à
rien le shooting toute la partie
si je veux travailler sur toi faut que
j'aie de la matière sans matière je suis
comme un agriculteur son puis ça c'est
que celle occupée de guillaume avec dans
quinze jours vous verrez guillaume c'est
quoi le projet sur les gros projets de
montrer aux téléspectateurs et vous
allez voir du rhône avant et un après ce
n'est qu'en fin d'année il ya une très
belle matière il a un très bon visage à
l'aide du poteau les indiscrétions vous
vous mettez combien de temps pour voir
cette routine beauté du matin et du soir
une petite heure quand mr louis et ses
morning routine c'est le morning meeting
pardon si ça marche ce que vous êtes
très beau cyril babin n'essayez pas
d'essayer de garder votre place lundi
isabelle très belle peau des yeux ah bon
moi moi bébé j'avais une poutre des
classes savez une peau à tendance
acnéique ah oui bah oui jamais autant
une marche mais la chine manque un peu
de bronzage quoi mais déjà regarder vous
avez votre m
lundi vous le savez isabelle présenter
touche pas à mon pape défi mais à la
base
isabella devait coanimer avec rené ouais
c'est rené malleville alors sonné j'ai
une petite question comment vous la
trouvez isabelle c'est ma copine aop
avril à merveille et si j'avais su que
parce que moi je croyais être seule
savons juste par le faire moi ironise
hervé morin d'adhérer à sanaa où les
habitudes je vois toi mais si j'avais su
cave et isabelle mais je suis revenu
avec un nom la prochaine fois
d'impressionnants fois si tu mets
isabelle je vis avec grand plaisir
alors là oui mais vous voulez mais bien
mais vous êtes un petit coquin rené nan
de petits coquins oui avec isabelle si
vous savez pas que l'indiqué partout me
dit je suis en plateau qui vont à
l'action sans qu'il aura des problèmes
vous savez où je suis maintenant dans
les regarder
un communiqué je voulais pas tout seul
ah oui mais maintenant je voulais pas
faire tout court et j'avais décidé de
sortir deux numéros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au lieu de 5 millions isabelle elle est
magnifique
franchement la savoie nuit-là sur
l'écran oui surtout la non mais non mais
là aussi très belle elle est magnifique
arrêté franchement les deux vous faites
un beau couple surtout si vous n'étiez
pas en couple vous auriez c'est un
couple magnifique année moi j'adore rené
ab je sais mais ça aurait pu me fait
rire il en plus il est n'est pas du tout
sûr excité en loge il est super sympa
ils vous regardent à prendre ou à
laisser attentivement dont la dore
aunisiens vrai vrai pote mode century
girl a par ailleurs précisé que la
question c'est pas ça tu veux coucher
avec lui ou ses passagers potentiels
reçu c'est ouais ça fait 20 ans qu'on le
dit alors qu'avez vous parce que j'ai du
dossier sur vous aussi platonique la
question si l'harmonie japan le plateau
la question se pose pas puisque isabelle
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va et amitié alors on a d'autres
choses isabelle c'est mort pour vous il
ya une autre femme qui a tapé dans
l'oeil de rené non ce n'est pas d'une
chroniqueuse c'est une invitée de cette
semaine on savait qu'ils parlent a bien
fini le doyen fine exact on joue il ya
vécu je venais vraiment sont nés tous
les deux se regarder ses 50 nuance de
rooney voilà j'adore propose d'abord
qu'on revoie le baiser oui on l'appela
ouais ouais regarde rhône et la bouche
ouverts celui ci arrive
putis monomère route claire et fraîche
qui dit en bonne mère
classement 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi c'est rooney radostar le
gars qui présentait l'émission avec moi
apple césar leoni je suis fière s'en
faisait lui sauva d'ironie qui a avoué
virginie ledoyen
je sais aux momies dorlot de plateau
c'est le banquet bien on invitera votre
ami a fait plaisir on a autre chose
mais oui parce que quand on voit à rené
avec isaac emploi rené avec virginie
ledoyen
on se dit ça y est on tient le nouvel
étalon de l'équipe mais c'est en fait
non il ya quelqu'un qui a doublé tout le
monde
non on n'a pas vu venir et c'est pas
jean michel c'est bernard monteiro
amélioration un soin lui c'est par la
trappe ce que je peux à mon âge pas
grand chose
bon arrêtez vous avez une grande
épuisette bernard que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils voulaient faut tout à bon oui
bernard je peux vous le dire aujourd'hui
d'être un goujat déjà en plus j'ai des
projets j'ai reçu voilà déjà un goujat
[Musique]
la beauté
le combattant je suis arrivé dans un
état de fatigue 6h ce matin le jet privé
monaco déjeuner alors hélicoptère après
nice élitiste
avec le prince albert re liquoreux
j'aurais pas la pêche en mer quant à son
symbole chimique mais choisir il s'est
tu seras biocare berges des oueds
[Musique]
beaucoup
jamais en main
[Musique]
mais non
témoin ce
[Musique]
eh bien
[Applaudissements]